so good morning
dear prime minister
it's very nice to have you here to greet
you here in Brussels congratulations
once again on your appointment as Prime
Minister of Latvia
and I'm very much looking forward to
working with you and this is the first
step we are doing actually there's a lot
of work to do the first topic that I
want to mention in our common work is
your unwavering support to Ukraine and I
really want to thank you for that Latvia
has backed our successive ways of
sanctions against Russia and our
different financial aid packages for
Ukraine you have been from the very
beginning a strong supporter so we are
really grateful for that the Europe's
for European financial support remains
of course a Lifeline for this country a
country that is so bravely fighting for
its freedom and for its future and this
is why the commission has proposed a new
facility for Ukraine in our proposal for
revision of the EU budget
you recall this these are 50 billion
euros till 2027 as support for Ukraine
we have started the discussions in the
European Union on that
here too I want to thank Latvia for a
very constructive role that you are
playing driving these discussions on not
only the facility for Ukraine but the
whole revision of the budget forward it
is money that Ukraine needs now and it
will continue to need it for the future
for the Reconstruction for example the
recovery but also for the reforms on its
path to the European Union
this brings me to another topic I'm sure
we will discuss today and that's the
topic of enlargement
this is not only
call of history but it's also a
geopolitical necessity
we need to set a vision
for successful enlargement and this is
why the commissioner started working on
a series of pre-enlargement policy
reviews it's basically the question on
how our institutions our budget our
security guarantees would work and I
would be very eager to listen to your
views on that one
Latvia itself is a shining example
of successful integration an integration
that you continue to deepen even almost
20 years after you joined the European
family for example I'm very glad that
you are fast forwarding by one year your
synchronization with the Continental
European grid
it will this fast forwarding will
disconnect you from Russia and Belarus
so it's good for your energy security
and it will also facilitate your uptake
of renewable energy to set the green
transition fully in Motion in Latvia
here next Generation eu's investment
plan for the future will of course
support you on this path
now my last point you have just we have
just received your revised Next
Generation EU plan yesterday including
the repower EU chapter
um it can certainly unleash significant
additional resources for clean growth
and good jobs so let's work on that one
together
my final final topic is migration
Europe continues to stand in full
solidarity with you
because we've seen Belarus cynical and
inhuman instrumentalization of migrants
over the past years we have deployed
frontex personnel and mobilized 63
million euros in additional funding for
Border surveillance
we continue to closely monitor the
situation at the border these hybrid
attacks carried out against our member
states are all more reasons why we need
a swift political agreement on t two key
proposals the one is The Pact of
migration and Asylum this is key to have
the common rules in the European Union
and the other one is indeed the revision
of the multi-annual EU budget the
so-called mff where we have also a
Top-Up for migration so we have a lot to
discuss it is all in preparations of the
Summits that are coming up the European
political Community then we have the
informal Summit in Granada and
afterwards we have the former European
Council here in Brussels once again a
very warm welcome to Brussels
thank you
they are Ursula thank you for your warm
welcoming me
and today I'm starting my first working
visit in Brussels as a newly appointed
Prime Minister of Latvia I'm very
pleased that the first meeting here in
Brussels is with the president of the
European commission Ursula of Van Der
Lane we are in agreement on many issues
which has made our cooperation easy
beneficial and productive
in this geopolitical situation I would
like to clearly state that Latvia's
position on the different EU policies
will remain unchanged
my government will keep a clear
pro-european approach Latvia can only be
strong and prosperous as strong as
European Union
it also reflects the Viewpoint of Latin
Society we are observing a record high
level of support for the EU in Latvia
the war in Europe continues Russia is
attacking independent Ukraine
my government will continue to urge for
the EU strong support for Ukraine as
long as it takes
I would like to express my deep
gratitude to you
the Jerusalem for your strong leadership
for supporting Ukraine
and our cooperation has been really
excellent
I will gladly discuss discuss with your
further support for Ukraine in more
detail financial and Military Support as
well as its integration in the EU
we will talk about fast sanctions
against Russia and the issue of Russia's
accountability of aggression
we will also discuss challenges of
migration in Europe including
lukashenka's hebrewed attacks on the
Eastern borders of the European Union
this is part of a wider destabilizing
Trend in our region
which requires a clear EU reaction
our response to all mentioned challenges
should be stronger and more resilient
European Union
thank you thank you very much
I take you upstairs
foreign